the fallout from the pandemic has begun
even before some care homes say they're
not yet sure they're over the worst of
the outbreak this care home in County
Durham is part of a group of four and
had over a hundred residents six died
from coronavirus but its owner operator
says the high number of deaths across
the country in care homes has left the
industry fighting for its own life are
you finding that relatives are losing
faith in sending their loved ones to
care the level of fear is quite high so
we're not getting the inquiries we're
just getting people voting with their
feet and so what that means is in the
long term six months six months hence
from now care homes will be under
serious pressure as they start to empty
out giving evidence at the Health and
Social Care Select Committee care
England the largest representative body
for social care in the UK gave this
damning assessment of the government's
treatment of care homes we should have
been focusing on care homes from the
start of this pandemic what we saw at
the start was a focus on the NHS and
that meant that care homes often had
their medical support from the NHS
withdrawn we also had the disruption of
our supply chains on PPE there were
cases I think of people who either
didn't have a code with 19 status or
were symptomatic who were discharged
into care homes even the government's
own ministers are now appearing to
question the handling of the crisis and
the reliance on science to shape
government policy if this science was
wrong advice at the time was wrong I'm
not surprised if people who then think
we made a wrong decision but you have to
take judgments based on what you have
the government says it's provided nearly
4 billion pounds to local authorities to
deal with coronavirus including in care
homes
if formally and in the more
responsibility for care homes is for
local councils I think this actually
raises a question not just for the
crisis but for the longer term when I am
held accountable at this despatch-box
for me for the actions of local
authorities I can give them
I can give support but we do not have
the direct levers that doesn't mean much
to the care homes reliant on additional
funding adequate funding proper funding
needs to be set aside the funding issue
needs to be resolved permanently going
forward and then it needs to be assured
and ring-fenced too so that the right
amount of money gets through to the
coalface the question now to what extent
did protecting the NHS mean overwhelming
some care homes Lisa Holland Sky News